what is going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are back to watch a movie that I
I've been dying to watch this Tara I it's
been on the top of my list for months and
when you said you hadn't seen it I said come
over tomorrow yeah here we are finally going
to watch this Freaky Friday it's weird that
I have not seen this because I've heard a
lot about it and then I saw the article come
out that they're going to put out another
one with the same cast I'm excited guys you
know what to do leave a like leave a like
if you enjoyed this video and ring that
follow Tara Erickson on her YouTube channel
where she does reactions as well over there
thank you to all who have followed us on our
patreon page becoming super sexy rejects over
there we do full length Reaction watch Songs
We sync it with your own copy of Freaky Friday
you can watch the whole thing with us on Cut
and we cover plenty of things over there exclusively
with the reaction highlights and watch along
is included Tara you already get freaky I'm
ready to get free I burped during that sentence
so that means I'm extra ready to get freaky
or not a woman my body is ready my mind is
ready the groups are ready let's do this let's
do it
day and night it's only right what an interesting
choice like yeah this is a Vibe right here
happy together six o'clock time it's too early
that's when the switch should happen [Music]
I like to switch your music to represent the
generations [Music] get acquainted with the
routine so I'm just gonna get a little
end of discussion feet down you you women
oh kill me Anna what he's in this Chad Michael
Murray yes I think he's gonna talk to you
that's older he was so skinny hello he's in
high school you pervert sorry he's still cute
when I want a leprechaun ice sculpture not
even Irish could you hold on a second whoa
you should be looking at the road we almost
hit that pedestrian and really somebody's
gonna die here
oh that's embarrassing a lot of embarrassing
moments up top here f sweet choker though
[Music]
oh creepy teacher you completely missed the
point of the book it's a blatant attack on
totalitarianism about a rigid Society dominated
by one all-powerful ego tripping dictator
my grade is final except he had hair oh he's
your teacher girl and up
you have to wear a clipboard that says detention
on it you're counting the minutes aren't you
no how many minutes are left 54. all right
this morning was good but then I got up
that sounds like my everyday
you know I'm surprisingly good at volleyball
anyway
oh my God hit her in the head yeah come on
now Clover her oh nice I'm gushing
turkey meatloaf yes Elizabeth I'll be at the
appointment tomorrow and Elizabeth remember
you are a smart strong beautiful independent
woman and you don't need a man to complete
you
bye Goodbye Oh my God
thank you
a guitar pick are they gonna Vibe over music
see you in a band sorta what do you mean sorta
well you know we're still stuck in our garage
face
you go to his bedroom
so what do you say you want to ride for sure
there you go you can wear my extra helmet
a Ducati how does he afford that he's in high
school you like the hives they're awesome
oh look I've got this important I was thinking
maybe if you wanted to we could get together
block
oh and he's gone he's just like that so dreamy
off into the sunset yeah
it's an original song sounds like it
oh sweetheart um all right ready I kind of
deserved it he was playing drums on her guitar
if she divorced her as the dad dead great
question what
what I thought I'd ask the author
damn she really learned how to play guitar
I don't know I don't think that's her there's
no way oh that is that is mean rude come on
Mom let us Rock one of the Bands dropped out
of the wangle Tango auditions and we are the
first alternate shut up oh no Jamie Lee you
better not sabotage get it together that's
my mom's rehearsal dinner Anna come on come
on so is her mom's rehearsal yeah she getting
married y'all we're screwed yep yeah [Music]
you know her mom put so much attention into
helping her patients but is neglecting her
family's emotional needs emotional well-being
with Stacy Hank house going to end never
[Music]
you've got an F in English today well Mr Bates
is out to get me you know he just looks for
ways to torture me like today the One Time
Jake even spoke to me he totally is Jake uh
oh he's just this really amazing guy mom where'd
you meet him detention but no outside of detention
oh is it like a fortune cookie situation uh
oh that would be awesome try and do better
mom I'll really really try all right what
do you want because this really important
audition that we're having tomorrow night
that we could never have again at the House
of Blues Anna I need to talk to you right
I think I'm gonna pass on that now why are
you getting so serious let's talk about it
I really want to understand I really do want
to understand Anna oh mama stay out of it
please no love it they're interfering they're
meddling Anna high school is not that hard
you couldn't last one day in my high school
challenge accepted I felt it you think my
life is perfect oh I know your life is perfect
your perfect job perfect boyfriend perfect
you're about to learn so much you
[Music]
know you're all right
okay thank you this is gonna be begging to
get back to Stacy in volleyball after one
minute in her mom's life
Journey soon begin it's prize reflected in
another's eyes and what you see is what you
lack will change you back [Music] they didn't
have to eat it whoa honey
yeah oh
everyone's dead
yeah okay an earthquake oh an earthquake no
there was no earthquake you didn't feel it
no I don't think so it was an emotional metaphor
interesting
spooky so the Chinese woman's the villain
how does that keep going that's cool [Music]
uh so the switch must have happened already
let the games begin breaking act two
I better get up I'd better
why am I in Anna's room
[Music] Hannah come here quick what mom's
dead I'm dead I'm dead
foreign [Laughter] [Music]
look I think something's happened to us what
are you oh my god this is my mother that's
so good
clone free
look at me I know we seem to be incredible
[Laughter]
I want my body back and I don't want mine
my weddings tomorrow I carry Ryan ew you're
in my body and I'm in your body why don't
we like adult okay you go over there and I
go over here go
oh
ouch I was just teaching Mom some new dance
moves what do you want Punk
[Music]
honey [Music]
did them okay I'll take it sweetheart what
are you doing here I thought you said you
needed a ride to work Mom I guess you better
hurry up
go to work I will go to school and you will
stay right what Evan Evan who's Evan oh my
neediest patient I've been seeing him every
day for the past three years that's not healthy
I mean what am I supposed to say to the freak
nothing you are in no way to give anyone any
advice that would be unethical just listen
attentively not occasionally you really want
us to be Each Other Well we will get to this
morning as each other and then we will go
back to the restaurant at lunch and get switched
back now go get dressed they're really good
at this Switcheroo yeah it's great you pierced
your navel yeah I meant to talk to you about
that when did you do this at Maddie's cousin's
sweet 16 . what is she what is she doing I
don't know why you never wear these they're
so cute what if you're selling Bible oh my
God what's up
so good while I'm apologizing let me just
say to the whole car how truly poor I am for
being such an insane control freak all the
time I'm the one who should be apologizing
for my flagrant disregard for anyone's feelings
but my own
yeah kiss him great we're getting married
isn't it even though my husband died how quickly
I've been able to get over it just pull up
here oh sick burn you manage alien Ryan in
my body that'd be nice but don't kiss him
oh Mom I just had breakfast that's disgusting
she's great at this
[Music] that is the last thing I'm going to
give him just look at him you don't even know
him I know he's too old for you oh my God
he's coming over here say hi back now say
hi back I'm gonna break with Ryan this is
my mother Dr Coleman
hi
oh my goodness it's a great bike not like
I've ever been on it I'm not allowed I mean
I'm allowed because I'm old
I gotta go [Music]
[Laughter] I've got the highs for you had
enough you know but they're coming to town
next week I was wondering if maybe you wanted
that's a really nice thought and I'm sure
with a haircut you'd look quite presentable
you truth be told you're way too old for me
you're sabotaging this [Music] he's so cute
and he brought your CD Hi how are you wonderful
[Music]
oh I hate Stacy oh nice stunt so we saw you
tell me what would Jake give us the dirty
detail excuse me I don't believe in physical
contact with the opposite sex
need a ride home you're gonna pick up the
Volvo most definitely be picking up the Volvo
huh yeah [Music]
[Music] shopping spree yeah
ah [Music] tell me other things I wanna hear
whoa oh she's going all oh my goodness full-on
makeover [Music]
oh
nice oh my goodness
I have the rehearsal dinner you look fantastic
are you canceling the session Kevin Evan Evan
F M oh so you don't answer your phone I told
you I wouldn't be able to call you on your
honeymoon but you lied to me you're a liar
I'll get it my God it's insufferable a thousand
dollars for what what kind of caterer are
you it's just sting so Ethan Evan Evan I knew
that it's getting work done with all that
phone ringing yeah and she's not gonna be
any food at the wedding I've seen him that's
good like every day in this torture chamber
oh my god did Bates have a crush on the mom
what are the central conflicts in Hamlet well
political of course because Claudius deserved
his father's Throne edible because of the
undercurrents with his mother nice is he really
seeing his father's ghost or is he simply
mad that is seriously overreaching what a
dick I hate him depressed you know then I
got all right anyway
he's not gonna look for people who are looking
to go to betterhealth.com Rejects I'm concerned
doctor that she and this boy might be you
know stop stop nothing is going on between
her and the sky because if there was she wouldn't
be writing about it in her diary she'd be
out there doing it hmm and he probably even
flirted with her a little bit but he secretly
likes your daughter he just hasn't made his
move yet because that wouldn't be cool so
now her best friend is acting like some psycho
freak interesting I never would have thought
about it that way cool guess we're done
oh God they're going to be financially broke
Beats Elton Bates Griffith High School how
do you know that you asked me I mean my mom
did this is taking it out on her daughter
aren't you aren't you I don't know what you're
talking about come on it was a high school
dance I mean you've got to let it go and move
on man I'm sure the school board would love
to hear about your pathetic Vendetta against
an innocent student yeah yeah well I don't
think Elton Bates will be giving me much trouble
anymore it's so weird about your mom oh yeah
what did she say that one
that's great well it is her rehearsal dinner
I mean don't you think that's rather important
too don't give us this energy is totally ruining
our lives
if it were any other night but tonight whatever
Anna I don't think the rehearsal dinner is
a good idea considering the current plight
you're in [Applause] [Music]
whoa uh get out of the car I'm driving oh
my god what have you done to me do you like
it right now [Music] you cannot eat fast food
why not because it will go down your throat
and drop instantly to my thighs this food
will make you blow up like a balloon but it
will do nothing whatsoever to me oh Mom now
there's long-term effects oh God this is good
Mom that's not fair my first French fry in
eight years eight years she is not living
[Music] whoa when we woke up this morning
we weren't ourselves yeah oh mama oh this
has happened before
what did she say oh she's crazy
when the fortune come true
how about 10 off cater no but no Pepe told
you we have a caterer actually mom there's
something I forgot to tell you good idea how
about I do
you have to be at Harry School in 15 minutes
mom yeah how different she walks he is a sweet
boy but he's having a little trouble with
bullies so that's character building you know
he's very good in English I um I had the class
write an essay on who they admire most and
he wrote a wonderful paper about your daughter
wow what
that's so sweet she showed me the paper you
wrote about Anna you saw that little before
I like her because we have too much fun fighting
that is so touchy I love that why does this
have to be world war three I mean all those
years of trick-or-treating and sleepovers
sit with me communication that's all it takes
oh God
look at you you again redress you're sexy
losing sore I don't see anything I don't know
oh my gosh that was amazing still got your
eyes oh my goodness she's gonna be on a show
you're on the Dottie Robertson show because
we're ready for you now Dr Coleman I know
you get nervous but you're gonna be great
oh no you want to prepare for something like
this you don't surprise someone with a television
appearance yeah
[Music]
foreign
she's copying my test [Music] Stacy gets attention
I hope Stacy gets beheaded loved your book
I actually read this one I actually read this
one now what got you what you did in the physical
and intellectual exhaustion that Sor let's
say no longer 20. it's an Essence like senile
old people got it got it
hey
that's cruel but do it Stacy's so mean show
your stand-up guy Chad Michael she had her
chance
do you want to know why adults are so tired
all the time because they spend all their
time obsessing about these stupid lame things
they don't really have to do oh like a cookie
have you never heard of takeout let's don't
say we did quality time
it's called the reading between the lines
oh my God let's just say this cute guy asks
you out what are you gonna do
oh
Hurry Up This Guy's hot water out God your
mom's cool [Applause] [Music] [Applause] that's
great I mean I saw what you did to Stacy's
test I think you're right you're too young
for me
stand up guy leaving her in the dust that
guy doesn't exist can I have a quad shot caramel
latte
I work here hey you know I caught the show
and you were you're great oh my God he's gonna
beat her oh yes you like The Vines I got the
bootlegs shot
that kid is so cute oh my gosh they're falling
in love you should be working yeah what are
you doing just sitting down
[Music]
uh this is so awkward I feel like I know you
go really I just please
oh my gosh
okay okay
no
[Music]
bad situation what you were doing on the eve
of our wedding straddling some guy on the
back of a big black Harley the Ducati the
Ducati my mom wouldn't let me go out with
him so I just had to beg her to check him
out for me and she did he's a very together
young man and she approves
really [Laughter]
I know
I must confess I still believe that is so
awkward I know it's unconventional okay and
I know nothing can happen I'm not stupid I
just you're behaving pretty stupid I want
to be able to talk to her do not come near
my mother or her fiance do you understand
man I don't understand anything oh you really
need to find someone your own age
that's awkward that guy's a creep very awkward
take that guy it's just creepy he's obsessed
let's try to be selfless give me your hands
okay I'm being selfless are you being selfless
yeah I'm being selfless dude I'm really sorry
but couldn't we just borrow Anna for like
20 minutes we'd never ask you or like anybody
for anything ever again I am appalled at you
too I clearly said go oh nice guy what are
you still doing here go right now thank you
thank you so much no no no she's gonna be
terrible the role of insensitive stepfather
who couldn't care lesser thinks it's a stupid
rock band or any of the Preposterous things
you just said I'm not that guy Tess and if
that's who you think I am then this is never
going to work wow good for you I never pushed
Anna because I want her to like me on her
own terms in her own way you should be over
there oh go I can hold down the fort here
for 20 minutes
that's so sweet should have gave him a big
kiss on the lips serious fantasy
you like me at all you will just leave me
alone please no Creep from right here in Los
Angeles let's give it up for pink slip oh
my god get on the stage mom yeah come on now
[Music] oh God yeah at least Fake It come
on now [Music] oh God [Music]
this is humiliating just go out there and
just go act like kids are you gonna play it
backstage yeah I think so she better hey
[Music]
stressing me out [Music]
[Music] [Applause]
thank God
I'm in love with you now yeah [Music] [Applause]
[Music] that one part of the solo saved this
whole performance
selfless off switch
that quickly he changes his mind to Anna Gotta
Get A Life buddy yeah like what are you doing
don't you have like parties to go to I need
you to Tell Ryan that you need to postpone
the wedding I can see you're not ready for
this and I can wait I guess that I was just
so happy I wasn't thinking about what's best
for you and Harry just please let him know
that I love him and be as kind as you possibly
can for me that audition got her this job
not the years of worse she already had good
job Bingo baby now I know how Anna feels and
and what she feels is that no one could ever
take the place of her dad
somebody could be part of a new family its
own kind of cool new little unit that for
some special as Ryan that we would all just
make a little room [Music]
whoa now they all felt it
full shot
love it [Music]
what the hell just happened trust you you
don't want to know
a Chinese woman done good done good Chinese
woman and it's Catering by them
for everything I love you I love you too do
you think we could just rewind this whole
thing and start again
he has like the tiniest little scruff right
here
both you and your mom know what it's like
to kiss this guy awkward you go ask her then
you'll fart Hey now wait a minute wait if
I was your age oh okay well yes I don't mind
no [Music]
okay yay [Music] oh damn she gets to perform
at the wedding that's what I'm talking about
people surprise a guy directed it only women
can direct other women right I know that was
a really fun movie super fun I had a great
time the the kid thing was weird I forget
what his name is I'm just gonna call him Chad
Michael that part is weird but the rest of
it is great super fun they did such a good
job playing each other like so funny to see
Jamie Lee Curtis play Lindsay loh I think
I vice versa I I think I because movie's been
out for a long time um I think the one one
of the things I heard about it was that when
they did this movie they had each other like
record how they would do the lines oh and
they just did them that way to take some inspiration
from how they might ah I don't know if I'm
making that up that's great and very helpful
um yeah I if I if that is true uh you commented
in the comment boxes I'm pretty sure that
is something I heard that they actually did
for it smart um but yeah I thought they did
an excellent job I know this is because you
know like uh the body swap comedy kind of
or horror movies The Body Shop comedy movies
uh is a really fun genre but a lot of times
they can't really go well but let's pull it
off right yeah yeah they kind of just go for
like bits like raunchy bits or something like
that um I don't know if raunchy is the right
word but they usually just go for bits but
here they really had a they had a really solid
setup at the beginning of really getting you
to understand who they are in act one it's
not about when the switch route did happen
you you could uh feel the the tension of the
situations they'd be thrusted into yeah throughout
the journey and it's had a really good heart
throughout it was like amazing performances
I agree the heart in it like when um oh when
the the kid shows his paper his paper is about
his sister and then when Jamie comes out and
is like Oh I thought that was just so sweet
don't tell her I like her that's such a sweet
moment just to set up like the kid it's not
like he was forgotten about but their relationship
was covered between him and his sister and
then um obviously at the end when she's like
crying and I'm gonna do this selfless thing
for you it's it's probably tears yeah I teared
up too yeah that was really touching super
so sweet and for their ability to switch in
and out of care to play both characters and
really feel both the emotions I was like yeah
that is an impressive it's an impressive like
crying scene to pull off that I was like dang
like yeah both of them I mean obviously outstanding
actors in their own right but like in this
was I've never really have you seen The Parent
Trap I've never seen The Parent Trap either
I might not have I'm looking at her face going
like have I seen this movie I'm gonna cover
Lindsay Lohan's career backwards yes now let's
see her when she was like five see how she
did that I mean she's awesome I don't know
if I've seen The Parent Trap honestly yeah
what I remember would that be a movie or it's
like I've definitely seen The Parent Trap
uh would that be one of those movies because
right now I'm like I don't think I saw it
1998. I would you would you would have been
at least 30 32 at the time yeah around there
so surround that around that age yeah
yeah absolutely what would be the sequel to
this though would it be them switching I feel
like they would just be aren't they just I
mean are they just gonna like redo it yeah
what would be the purpose of them redoing
it
because this is kind of like a perfect film
in a lot of ways oh other than some creepy
undertones that they got that they got older
and they lost touch with each other as as
maybe mom and daughter and daughter gets distracted
with life and I'm married now and I have kids
and mom is still married with husband and
whatever and they've grown apart and now they
must intervene again to be like mother and
daughter have to come back to be like mother
and daughter again like closer that's how
I would play it so it's not the same movie
it's still the same actors are going to use
right yeah so like that would be a good way
like they've lost touch and so it has to happen
for them to like come back together or it
could be a commentary on today's climate when
it comes to the discourse that some people
have around the trans community and seeing
like how topical they can make it that's true
meaning like you know switching by right
I just wanted this video to take a very different
direction Gregory how far we can push a subject
I'm like I feel like in the movie they're
both female identifying females so I was like
no they might they might just be in the movie
but it might focused on different characters
okay all right well there he had his take
I had mine mine I want it to be political
the next one I wanted pickles commentary and
the serious consequences yeah okay yeah life
or death Stakes yeah I mean I think you can
make this like a dark psychological Thriller
they always make these body swap movies like
comedies and I think you could make this one
like a thriller you know yeah like get rid
of the like the fun like the fun heartfelt
like good times and just make it like dark
and like something that you think about when
you leave the movie theater for like hours
yeah like it messes with your psyche like
truly stepping into the mindset of the other
person and discovering their emotions and
the term like really uncover the term turmoil
must be like what's in their brain or not
you can just keep it cute that's Disney you
know how they do I mean I would take either
honestly yeah well anyway we'll transition
back to sincerity for a second here sure um
the Chinese people that could have been racist
they handled it well well yes yeah but they
did I mean I don't know if people would still
find a racist or not but I was like probably
where are we going with this they'd be like
oh they're in the typical role of where Chinese
people don't understand things and they just
like fortune cookies fortune cookies to like
make them yes people are going to be like
this is out of touch but um they were both
very funny great actresses I like seeing older
movies in the lens of how today would find
things problems it would go absolutely not
when I watch it and I'm like I have no issues
with anything of what they did here even Chad
Michael Murray and his creepiness I'm just
like it's just amusing to me just a movie
the Chinese stuff I'm like it's amusing it's
uh they can't really do that now but I would
love I love I love when like movies like this
get discovered on Twitter today I don't know
how dare they people like lose it I'm like
well it was fun I had fun watching even the
cliche of how they of how uh therapy has been
viewed so much in in film through so much
of so much of the years of like only only
like truly troubling crazy distraught people
yeah absolutely and it's it's really just
like normal people day to day who are like
I need somebody to talk to when really this
is just a comedy from a couple decades ago
I'm just preparing for you know how some people
are going to view it yeah I wonder I wonder
if it has had any type of turn like that but
it is kind of fun to see to pick and choose
which films are now problematic it has this
hasn't happened with Freaky Friday yet I just
think it's funny that I could totally see
a scenario where it could happen one day well
yeah if they've replayed the same games in
the in the new ones which they're not gonna
do that you should do it exactly the same
make them even more Chinese like more Chinese
stereotypes that would be hilarious
this this lived up to what I wanted to be
and it had more and had more emotion than
I actually anticipated expected yeah I thought
it was just going to be corny like campy comedy
uh and it actually had a lot of heart like
the ending I was like uh award-winning performances
here I believe both of them so much dropped
into those characters and like it was just
great I I was there with them and they made
me feel and I like that and other than the
exceptionally wild understanding and forgiveness
that the fiance Ryan has right other than
that I still really appreciate it because
at the end of the day it's certain kind of
moving you got a certain kind of tone that
allows you to get away with certain kind of
things certain kind of behaviors like that
I still really appreciate his height into
the switch bodies so with Ryan of how they
did turn him into like he evolved as a character
throughout it and and his intentions and what
like what he really wanted out of this relationship
how that came to light and how he helped motivate
the not only his relationship with Jamie Lee
Curtis but also um proxy helping to change
his relationship with the daughter yeah I
thought was really well done I thought it
was a great handling and like how you brought
the scene with the brother in in the parent-teacher
conference yeah of giving like a deeper understanding
like what's going on underneath the surface
of these characters so for a movie that has
her your your uh your your lead character
as a psychologist it is fun to see a movie
that does explore with like our four characters
what's going on underneath the service and
even with Chad Michael Murray at first going
oh let's not judge this guy we're off the
bat is just some like cool Rebel on a bike
right he's actually a really like a guy looking
for love so much so that he will he can get
very toxic and dangerous apparently [Music]
so desperate for love
is there something seriously off about him
in this room a little bit yeah it's creepy
I also
and how they frame it though like in the movie
you just like totally accept that like the
next day he's just fine and likes Anna even
though he has no idea that they switch bodies
like yeah I I I find that where I'm just like
oh okay but it's a movie and you accept it
um I think it's just played for it's played
for so much romance and you're supposed to
root version you're supposed to but you're
like you just got over her mom two seconds
ago yeah you were outside the house last night
singing to her and upset she was going to
get married trying to sabotage you you crashed
the rehearsal right like that that's a pretty
intense thing I would have liked it more if
it was a flip of like he is now distraught
and he's like I'll I'll I like you but I'll
I'll always love your mom and he like rides
off on the Ducati and no one's ever seen him
again that would be uh preferred in my opinion
and then she just is like Anna's there and
she dances with her little brother oh yeah
that would be sweet because now she would
no no she wouldn't know would she know she
does know about the letter and then maybe
he swoops in because Grandpa's like go to
this I go to dance but then the Santa comes
in she's like Hey kid like you want to dance
and then they dance and that's sweet and then
forget about Ducati guy because he's kind
of nice fell in love with Mom and now brother
and sister we see it again that they are now
gonna have a better relationship because he
because of the letter that's a good and you're
welcome I mean stick me in the writer's room
and call it a day kid would have brought it
back around to that storyline too that's not
bad Tara that's not bad not bad you're an
inventive human being thank you so much creative
yeah I hope our comments about Chad Michael
Murray's character overshadow everyone first
going wow I really love Greg and Tara's reaction
and then they're like no how dare you make
fun of her make fun of Chad the very obviously
creepy guy he just shouldn't have ended up
with her I think at the end like you were
in love with her mom two seconds ago yeah
there's like no he's being tossed I'm like
why are you so in love like why are you like
so if you look at the Timeline guys he had
just met properly Anna Thursday yeah Thursday
yeah right it was very even Thursday yes and
then Friday he's just like hunting them down
and the next day he's like I love you now
Anna also how did he not get fired from serving
her coffee and then he just sat down during
his place of work and nobody was like hey
buddy get back to work I'm like that was that
could have been a little bit of a goal like
comedy Gold Line where someone's like hey
man what are you doing like yeah you're supposed
to be we got a line back here and he's a senior
and I'm assuming no yeah I don't think he's
a senior he just like works there right because
see I was confused when he's like I just work
here and I'm like he had a teacher's key you
don't give that to students right or unless
he's a senior that also works there I don't
know it's complicated they should have explained
we gotta look at look everything that we're
supposed to love about this movie we love
we love I love I I this is a lot of fun I
love this movie I thought it was great it's
great there's just a lot of questions about
Chad Michael Murphy that I'm like he yeah
he yeah yeah questions I can't even get all
the words out uh I typed in Chad Michael Moran
Wikipedia what I meant to type in freaking
what is he up to now damn he is a handsome
guy though he is a very attractive I mean
if there's some guy who you can accept for
being a uh not a 2003 okay all right let's
uh are they gonna like okay we're gonna try
to learn about this all right okay is it earthquake
Blah Blah Blah Talk Show psychology like where's
his name he's not in here he's not they they
removed him from the Wikipedia okay let's
look up his character name and then we're
gonna they don't have like a list of characters
well they might we're gonna put it at the
bottom at the bottom of that paragraph yeah
okay his name is is Jake all right let's type
in Jake here okay Jake knows his ass okay
and now we're ready to watch the interview
on television doesn't say what he does he
loses his enamoration towards Anna after she
sabotages Stacy's test okay we gotta see if
there's anyone else on the internet that has
thought Jake is it Freaky Friday is crazy
is it still one of them is a student she's
a student because we would love to know um
18 or 19 and he does ACT immature so it makes
he does he didn't though okay it's not made
clear what is the age difference she's 15
he works at her school so this has been see
this has been oh my God we have been stuck
on he's obsessed and we haven't we've barely
even scratched the surface on how old is this
guy actually I guarantee you there is a Reddit
Forum that just discusses all of this yeah
there's a lot of people okay he wasn't just
an older guy at school he worked for the school
which is why he had access and they're like
that's weird people are saying it's weird
okay yeah we're not the only ones who thought
the only ones people think it's weird it is
weird like how are you stop hitting on high
school students if you work there how old
are you sir that's true I assume he was just
like 19 like it wasn't that crazy but still
I'm like what's I mean 15 and 19 is a that's
a big difference yeah she wasn't like a senior
yeah you're right I mean just get out of here
kid stop hitting on the girls at school yeah
it's crazy you work there bring him back in
the sequel and acknowledge all this put him
in jail lock him up that's what the sequel
should be about Jake in jail so
jail oh man there's a lot of it like he's
someone's [__] and he body swapped through
that person to jail that would be great no
because then you have to like then you're
like in jail there's no campy fun comedy really
in jail I think you can make something that
is totally confusing yeah where you're like
I don't know if I should be laughing at this
right or right or crying laughing or crying
that's a good place to put an audience in
right where they're like I'm not sure on the
edge of my seat should I have brought my children
or a box of tissues we don't know but uh yeah
Lindsay that's great she's so good in that
scene I'm like dang all right Lindsay I believe
she's great they're both so good in this she's
a great actress it's like crazy how yeah it's
I think that it's crazy how much she like
missed out on continuing to act I know she
had a recent like Netflix Christmas movie
I didn't watch it sorry I heard it's good
uh okay it's good that I'm like oh maybe she's
like back in the back in the swing of things
she just was gone for so long and she is she
is great I get how it would be hard being
a child actress because The Parent Trap popped
up and I'm like she looks five and I don't
think I've seen that movie so that means she's
been acting forever oh yeah no I think it's
it you have I think you have to really protect
a child actor who becomes famous yeah every
skill stranger things I have been Gravely
concerned about oh yeah uh yeah you have to
really protect it growing up in the spotlight
like that I just it's tough It's really really
that that's that is hard and it's so isolating
too in the sense of a lot of people would
assume like well no they're the kid with the
greatest life they get the fame and the fortune
at such a young age and so that it's even
more it's easier to be misunderstood and you
also have a harder time adapting to real life
and understanding people's motives and what
they might want from you and you know like
there's so many terrible things that I could
imagine creates this Snowball Effect oh yeah
um so yeah I I I I totally sympathize and
you're not as well equipped at that age to
deal with like the emotional um sort of torture
of like feedback on you and your career on
the choices that you've made and are you a
good actor or not like that's a lot for a
kid to handle because emotionally you're not
and your brain is not fully equipped either
and then when you're a child the actor especially
you know now we try to embrace like oh look
how real they are on social media there's
only a certain extent people can be real on
social media right yeah when you're a child
actor they really like freaking program you
to how to behave around people in total uh
and Beyond just how you are on set like they
really program you on that like that's one
of the cliches of like stage Moms come from
and how to be around casting directors and
adults and how to present yourself in public
and and all these things like yeah adults
get that with publicist but it's different
when you're learning to navigate it then when
you're a kid it's like you feel like you always
have to be a certain way so you're always
kind of handled yeah but here she felt like
such a real teenager you know yeah like if
it felt so it felt so real and and I respected
it a lot and Jamie Lee Curt is um because
I thought at the beginning I really think
like Jamie Lee Curtis like I mean she's Jamie
Lee Curtis one of the best actresses of all
time like right off the bat she just nailed
the switch the bottom switch like just all
of her nuances so good because they actually
played it really felt like they were making
the the effort to play the characters versus
you know let me just play this like a 15 year
old have you seen Shazam Fury of the Gods
no the latest is that the latest no because
I got a little upset about his mentee breakdown
um about John Wick 4 and not telling people
not to go see it and I was like sir you really
need to calm down and now I'm not gonna see
Shazam for a while even though I loved the
first one I'll see it I think it was slightly
edited the way that went down but now he's
kind of a social media like like it was like
John Wick four don't go see that see Suzanne
I haven't seen the full clip oh my gosh sir
I've never accomplished on it because I don't
know what the full clip of the context is
it was just kind of a lot and I was like listen
I think that the worst thing to do to promote
your movie the week before is not to throw
another movie under the bus and tell people
Shazam is a family-friendly movie John Wick
is not gonna be that it's just like and it's
a far better movie I swear to you he said
he either said far better or and it's a better
movie and I'm like you did say it's a better
movie I was losing my mind because uh number
one I'm like I don't even know if he's seen
it and number two you're wearing a mental
breakdown by trying to get people to go see
your film by throwing another film under the
bus I don't enjoy any of this he probably
went through it had a mental breakdown okay
I get it you were losing it and that's probably
not you as a person I enjoy it because you
know how I feel about John Wick I I think
though that you know sometimes it is important
in order to elevate yourself you got to throw
under other people under the bus yep John
Humphrey's a big piece of [__] guys you've
got to build your pedestal by walking on top
of other people if you make other people look
less than it makes you look better that's
how you elevate yourself this whole thing
about like if you try to elevate other people
elevates you no I could have really learned
from that video then is what you're saying
I got mad about it Shazam Fury the gods made
a lot of money
anyway I brought up that movie because um
one of the criticisms do you know the general
concept of Shazam of how he says Shazam and
he's a big boy's body big guy's body yes yeah
so the one of the criticisms that's really
been levied at it his name's Zach Levy haha
that's funny um that's been levied at it is
that um it doesn't seem like there's any real
melding of the of the two personalities of
young boy Billy and old boy Billy that he's
just like I'm playing a 15 year old doofus
and then in a grown man's body like it feels
like a completely different person and that
is not the case here like Jamie Lee Curtis
really captured that youth but really captured
what Lindsay Lohan was going for and still
making it her own as well without relying
too much on an imitation and I and she she
nailed that right off the bat and I felt Lindsay
Lohan um found her way into that as the movie
went in a much smoother way it's the point
where I was like oh now I really believe her
so especially if they sent each other like
like lines I would be like send me all the
lines I do not mind getting like a line read
and I'll make some of them my own but if you
can get a taste of like how she would say
it then you I feel like if they did that it's
very smart because then you could really drop
into the character if you're you're hearing
it you're able to like repeat it and go like
okay I feel like now I'm in Lindsay Lauren's
body or by vice versa um do people say vice
versa or vice versa vice versa yeah I heard
someone the other day maybe they said that
or said a different thing I'm like maybe I've
been saying it wrong the whole time did they
send each other tapes I mean now that I type
it in it's going to be a bunch of articles
about God freaking we don't have time I know
hold on let me try one more search Amy Lee
Curtis freaky Sprite sending like did they
like Jimmy's and Curtis sending Lindsay Lohan
like my recording lines Freaky Friday I was
saying recorded lines for each other okay
talk Freaky Friday come on touch for a sequel
which Disney sizes and it works already written
to Disney everything's about the sequel
stressing me really just like did they you
know what we could do we could just look it
up if it's a fact on IMDb um is pro it's probably
a a fun fact on IMDb oh yes okay let me now
let's just sift through these 335 facts quiet
Tara
great ideas you don't even know where to find
it where do you find it doesn't even know
where to find you fit on IMDb do you know
where they're located okay wait do I they're
like down hold on there's like somewhere here
somewhere down see did you know and you go
yeah right here did you know trivia which
asked what do you um uh your prompt okay that's
funny originally I did okay blah blah blah
Jody Foster he's a [__] Jody Foster as
I almost did them for Pope Francis another
character or okay had six days to prepare
for the role of Tess damn after net Benning
dropped out wow that's insane great job um
okay maybe I made that up I really thought
I really thought that was a truth I don't
know why I thought that I don't see anything
about it there's nothing here maybe I was
wrong you guys let us know in the comments
maybe they did we just didn't find it what
do you think about Freaky Friday leave your
thoughts down below do you think Chad Michael
Murray is creepy in this yeah let us know
I certainly think so hey let's do a patron
of the day shout out Michael B Omni media
he's got a really great reaction Channel closing
in on 50 000 subscribers well well well Michael
B I would love to body swap with you for a
day so that way you can experience what it's
like to run real rejects it's tough and then
I would experience what it's like to run your
Channel and then watch as I take it to surpassing
the real Rejects and subscribers wow in one
whole day one day showing my skills okay as
someone who reacts to stuff and what I'm capable
of doing and instilling I would literally
save every aspect of your channel he's literally
going to be sitting in the corner drinking
energy drinks crying over the editing yeah
in the dark and I'll be like these views because
this channel has not been around as long is
not getting as many views as I'm used to getting
and now I'm stressed out Michael he's gonna
have to see two therapists now and then watch
what I would love to happen is then you're
me on the channel and then people are like
hey Greg's different I love this new version
of Greg they love the new they love the new
Greg a lot whatever you've turned into Greg
we love it amazing um I I would I could there
I want people to be like wow I unsubscribed
because I couldn't stand Greg anymore right
but but then you get news because the new
Greg is wrong and then those subscribers who
unsubscribe they go they return oh they return
because new Greg is more enjoyable they like
the yeah so they leave and they all come back
so you're you're basically at square square
one yeah you're good okay and then my goal
to grow your channel actually tanks and uh
loses 20 000 subscribers so real rejects is
still standing presents us better than ever
with new Greg because Michael is being Greg
yeah Greg Bean Michael has caused Channel
his channel his channel it's to plummet and
Michael just he I guess after the Freaky Friday
Michael won't have the channel anymore yeah
but the real the old real rejects will still
be pumping them out huh yeah the new Greg
yeah okay I don't like this idea it's hurting
my ego is it yeah okay like I said you gotta
tear the people down to lift yourself up sure
yeah I mean we all knew you you needed a little
help it's like Greg is Greg right now he's
like he's fine yeah he could be a little bit
better right a little like there's there's
people that are they're agreeing right now
like you're he's I feel the stairs and I am
going there's people back there going yep
she's right there with me trust me just like
be just like sitting it you know what I mean
see what you've done you have elevated yourself
tearing me down so that's why I feel so good
right now how everyone's like I love Tara
more yeah she's a better person and she knows
more things absolutely feel great patron of
the day Shout [Music]